in the past getting an inside look at  living bugs was difficult during CTC  ends the careers would crawl and squirm  causing image smearing and artifacts  like many animals insects become  sedentary when expose the highest co2  environments so researchers at the  University of Western Ontario had an  idea  scientists subjected Colorado potato  beetles to a constant flow of co2 within  seconds the insects were not moving but  still alive with the beetles immobilized  researchers were able to get some of the  clearest images of bug guts to date with  the exception of a few older males the  subjects were easily woken up and the  exposure to radiation in co2 didn't seem  to harm the insects the researchers say  that with this quick and safe method of  knocking out bugs clearer looks at  insect insides or in the near future  while still on the inside of the bug  [Music]